I I said whether it was there ever a
time when you wanted to quit yeah oh the
same thing
what kept you going
um probably not having anything else
that I've ever done to pay my bills
because and and that would probably be
the truth and then when I'm on the set
I was doing a series in 2019 in Canada
in Vancouver which I love Vancouver what
series
sacred lies okay and I
was my dog was dying
and I was flying in and out and I was
exhausted
and I actually
uh when they were trying to do the deal
and business Affairs at Facebook Network
were really being dicks
uh and I was in the emergency room with
my dog
and he had had a stroke we didn't know
what
and my manager called over and over and
over and I finally picked up and was
like
I can't can't talk now that's what the
text meant when I said can't talk now
we've been together for 30 years my
manager and I so so we we can yell at
each other and not hate each other and
he said all right but just hear me out
here's the deal here's what they want we
have an hour and I said well then the
answer is no and I I I've never said no
to anything I can't say no
but it's powerful when you mean it
holding my dog I was like then if they
can't wait
well I'm in the freaking emergency room
goodbye and he took the job for me
anyway and now post pandemic or whatever
now endemic I'm glad he did right but
there was a lot around that job where I
didn't want to be there
but I remember standing there so clearly
waiting to enter the scene the scene was
happening in a bedroom on a set and I
could see a video Village and I could
see the boom guy
and
I was like getting ready to walk in and
do kind of a a great scene great writing
and I was like I love
actually I love this I love the set I
love these Kearney [ __ ] a bunch
of crazy bastards just making [ __ ] it's
the best the most creative
I mean the people that such good people
on cruise crews are always the most
wonderful the best just down to earth
real people I always I'm friends with
them I just feel I know from Indiana I
just want to hang out
right we're like yeah man these are the
best people ever but you love acting I
love acting
that part between action cut now
everything around it right like this we
don't get waiting take after take after
sitting oh my God after sitting after I
mean it's it's not glamorous people
think I've invited people instead I've
talked about this before and they're
like okay and then like why are you
doing this for the tenth time where do
you want to go tenth time they were so
excited we want to get the hell out and
you're like at 10 are you kidding
imagine doing it imagine doing it 12
hours and I'm gonna do it for another 50
takes you know and and my feet hurt and
uh God knows what that fog is I've been
inhaling for 20 years right I always
talk about something do we have to have
the [ __ ] fog it looks really cool
yeah it looks really cool when I'm dead
I know and I know they go it's fine it's
fine we did not do one scene on True
Blood without True Blood definitely with
vampires and [ __ ]
always had yeah yeah and we went to
nights every week you know so we flip
back and forth and our shoots
our shoots were minimum we started at 15
Day episodes and we ended up a 25 Day
episodes so we were doing three pages a
day so you're doing that wait a minute
50 25 wait how many what what's it again
say that again we did 25 days for every
20 days for every episode 20 days on
Smallville with all the Supernatural and
all the effects me to 10 days uh-huh
okay